Merry Christmas everyone it's Charlie
does that not give you a flashback just
to make a flash pun to season 1 episode
9 that mid-season finale where he said
Merry Christmas and you finally got the
reveal that he really was the
reverse-flash because of the yellow suit
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video but I know there's all
kinds of questions about what the ending
meant and along with what's going on
with next week's episode because it's
like full-blown battle mode remember
there's only six episodes left including
tonight's episode meaning that they're
gonna be wrapping things up pretty soon
because there's only one more bus metal
left but the circle is now complete
the student is the master that reference
was also very timely because even though
it was meant as a joke during the Barry
elongated man scene like he's starting
to learn he's becoming a better hero so
the student really is starting to become
the master but it's also very subversive
with Harry's storyline because now he
the student is becoming more like the
master the Harrison wells
eobard thawne from back in season one
because of what he's doing here inside
the Time Vault and what he might
eventually become using the dark matter
with the thinking cap
[Music]
so top 10 WTF Easter eggs let's do it
number 10 J in Silent Bob episode of the
flash if you guys didn't know Kevin
Smith directed this episode he told a
big story on his podcast about how the
producers asked him to be in the episode
and they were like you know would J
wanna be in this because it was gonna be
a comedic moment so if Silent Bob
himself is gonna be directing the
episode then why not go for it and he
said that it took him a minute to say
yes but eventually he did and they had a
lot of fun and he's like I'm not playing
Silent Bob the character but I don't
speak so think of that what you will
Kevin Smith has directed a couple
episodes in the past but this is the
first one I think that he's guest
starred in Jason Mewes actually got to
guest-starred during a couple episodes
during season 2 during the Xoom season
he got to be one of the background
figures with a costume on but he also
got to be that annoying character with
the hummer earlier in the episode I
think that was from the same episode I
think he just played two different
characters but within the Jay Silent Bob
joke number nine they actually drop a
big black atom reference the crown of
con dog you steal from black atom you
get lit up it's as simple as that
just do not do it they did the same
thing on Smallville where it's like yeah
they're probably not gonna be able to
use the black atom character but you can
reference conduct all you want because
it really does exist I think they even
used conduct during Batman V Superman so
they're just sort of like laying the
groundwork for eventual Shazam black
atom stuff in the universe because we do
have sorry on legends of tomorrow and I
can't say her actual comic-book name in
the video because YouTube will flag it
because it's the same name as a
terrorist organization but you get the
idea eventually we'll get some black
atom it might just take a long time
number eight breacher is back always fun
to see Danny Trejo on they drop all
kinds of dusk till dawn references if
you haven't seen that a long time badass
Quentin Tarantino really good grindhouse
movie but also a lot of really cool
Danny Trejo in it too this is what he
looked like during that you don't
realize it but this movie was a long
time ago but it all sort of works with
the vampire reference so just a reminder
that we now have vampires in the DC
Universe but they're on a different
earth so who knows if we'll ever see
them during a crossover episode but
Oliver Queen Vampire Hunter does sound
like a lot of fun see if he wants to do
a vampire episode of arrow in the future
but number seven we get the null
character
so I wasn't a super big fan of the
actresses portrayal of the character but
I talked a little bit about her during
my trailer video the character actually
debuted during the Hawk World comic book
they had that really funny reference
during legends of tomorrow's finale the
stupid chicken people still not totally
sure after the episode why the thinker
needs her powers in particular because
he already has repulsor technology but
because she was flying around at the end
of the episode manipulating her own
relative gravity maybe that's what he'll
use it for like it'll just give him the
ability to seemingly fly even though
that's not exactly what's happening
number 6 was the comedy bit where
elongated man pretends to be Joe and
they go to interrogate Carson Beckett
from Stargate they bring that character
back you know he's a bit of a weird
character this a little over the top but
I'm a huge stargate fan I love the
character when he was on that TV show so
I give him a bit of a pass on that if
they only used him a little bit but the
real reason for this scene being so
awesome is the fact that it's Jesse
Martin having fun pretending to be
elongated man pretending to be Joe West
so it's just fun to watch Jesse Martin
pretend to be really silly it's just
like that fake play from Thor Ragnarok
where you have Anthony Hopkins the actor
pretending to be Loki pretending to be
Odin so you have Anthony Hopkins being
really ridiculous as his Odin character
ocean number five was Marley's realizing
that she'd been roofied with those tears
so it sets off this Westworld
arc if you're not a West world fan that
shows actually getting ready to start I
do videos for it so I would recommend
you check it out but a big part of the
season one plot was the way that they
treated the robots on that show so
sometimes they'll slowly achieve
consciousness they'll realize what's
going on in the people that run the park
will have to reboot their minds and
it'll become this big loop where
eventually events will lead to them
slowly regaining a form of consciousness
then they get rolled back again so they
call that a loop so Marley's has been on
a loop and we find out number four even
bigger WTF this has been happening over
and over again how many times does it
happened too many times so this is one
of the worst crimes that the thinker has
probably committed this form of spousal
abuse where he's doing the thing that
they actually highlighted during the
hero arc so remember when elongated man
had that line of dialogue and said
you're not doing what's good form
me you're doing what's good for you
Barry Barry was making the selfish
choice Cisco did the exact same thing
there was a parallel with the breacher
storyline - Cisco lied - breacher
because he was worried he wouldn't get
to keep seeing [ __ ] and it almost led
to breach or dying so the whole idea is
is that eventually Cisco does the right
thing tells the truth - breacher Barry
does the right thing with Ralph
but because the thinker is the villain
of the season does not do the right
thing and continues to abuse his wife
and puts her on another loop in that
very last scene that they had in the
episode was the exact same thing that
happened at the beginning of the episode
just indicating that she had started
another loop the big thing I think
they're foreshadowing here is that team
flash will eventually find out what's
going on they'll try to help her and
Marley's will be critical in defeating
the thinker so they included a lot of
moments and a lot of dialogue in the
episode to remind you of really
important ideas that I think that
they'll pay off later like being
unpredictable telling the truth working
together as a team they all sound like
platitudes but trust me those will be
very important for defeating the thinker
later on number three was the fart save
at the end of the episode obviously like
the bar yeah bizkaia funny a little bit
gross but the real thing is is look how
far his arm can stretch like that's
crazy he goes above one of the buildings
like that just nuts they kind of did
that earlier this season like you always
wonder what are the upper limits of his
abilities his powers actually work a
little bit more like plastic man's
powers in the comics rather than the
traditional elongated man Plastic Man is
different because he can mimic anything
he even turns himself into a shredder
during the dark nights metal story and
shreds a bunch of enemies but again I
think the real reason that the thinker
wants Ralph's powers is so that he can
get his old body back although he does
have a lot of other abilities it's just
that there's usually like one thing that
he wants from each of the metas number
two was Cisco potentially leaving the
show down the road breachers like hey
you know I'm gonna go to that dragon
farm on earth 47 get your Khaleesi on
have some Game of Thrones fun I'm not a
Khaleesi so many good breacher
one-liners like I just see them standing
off-screen giving Danny Trejo different
funny lines to read like try this one
talk about using your knife as a mirror
because you don't want people to think
that you're a little girl
the whole thing with
Cisco is is that the actor actually
tweeted this out in response to danielle
Panabaker tweeting this out say it isn't
true are you potentially leaving the
show and he's like is this clickbait is
this drama what's going on the thing
they might do because I don't think that
the actor is like full-blown leaving the
show is that it might be a Willa Holland
arrow situation where they just leave
for a couple episodes then they come
back so the internal logic for why he
would be gone for a couple of episodes
it's just because he's working with the
breachers there's really only one big
reason to send him away before the end
of the season and that would be to leave
bury a man down in the fight against the
thinker like you take away some of the
chips the team flash has it makes it
harder for them to win but it almost
feels like they're setting up more of a
season 5 plot like that'll play out over
the course of that season so like he'll
come in and out of episodes I think it
makes it easier for them to balance the
cast so that everybody doesn't have to
be in every single episode you don't
have to give everybody a storyline like
if Cisco's not gonna be doing anything
in an episode it would make sense that
you just don't include him in the
episode so that you could focus more on
the other characters that are bigger for
the story that week so I think that's
all that's going on but as far as I know
the actor is still a main cast member
but remember we still have five more
episodes to go so I think they won't
make more season 5 announcements about
the cast like who's staying who's going
who the new people are gonna be until we
get to the summer so just put a bookmark
in that but number one of course is the
return of Gideon using the reverse
flashes gear to juice up the thinking
cap with dark matter and that's what's
going on here if you're not sure what it
is he's hooking this up for he's going
to do the thing that Cisco told him not
to do don't use dark matter like the
thinker used because it was as big
running plotline in the episode where
Harry got pissed off that the thinking
cap wasn't working the way it was
supposed to because they were preventing
themselves from juicing up their
thinking cap with as much energy as the
thinker did but the problem is is that
now it seems like he's turning into more
of a villain the more he uses the cap
especially with scenes like this that
make him seem almost exactly like season
eobard thawne Harrison wells so that's
why you see him hesitate when he puts
his hand like he's thinking about it do
I really want to do this then he puts
his hand down
in its Morena Baccarin as gideon
remember the legends of tomorrow gideon
even though it's the same program it's a
different actress doing the voice for
that so i am so happy that they brought
her back for this rather than use the
new actress because it just keeps it in
continuity on the flash TV show it's
always been the same voice of gideon on
the flash but remember he's juicing up
the thinking cap and he has access to
future knowledge so it sounds like he's
just gonna try and cheat so to speak you
know take the shortcut remember that
Star Wars reference now I am the master
he's slowly turning into Harrison wells
reverse-flash now not necessarily
physically becoming and he's not gonna
have his powers he'll be a very
different kind of villain but because
they made the Star Wars reference short
cuts anger hate pave the path to the
dark side so it's sort of like Anakin
Skywalker falling from grace slowly
seeking a shortcut to cheat death
because now Harrison wells is seeking a
shortcut to beat the thinker can't go
wrong with a lot of classic Star Wars
but let me know if you spotted any
Easter eggs that I didn't mention in the
video and what your favorite moment was
we also have to talk about what's gonna
happen to Harrison wells
if they continue down this path because
they could be setting him up to be a
season 5 villain if he goes off the deep
end what will happen is is I'll post my
flash trailer video tomorrow morning
I'll name the giveaway winner when I
post that click here for that brand new
Thanos infinity war trailer and click
here for my legends of tomorrow finale
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight